around forty to fifty thousand israelis
that live in the bay area
so the connection that and and the
impact that they're making is incredible
but they're making incredible not only
within the companies but
also you know within their own
communities and when you walk when you
meet people
in in the silicon valley and you say
israel everybody says yes i know.
and then i know this guy i know that guy
knows and
and this is you know that is a
representation here
and that's so important welcome to 20
minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel welcome to 20
minute leaders
how does tech and diplomacy meet well
we're about to find out meet shlomi
kaufman the consul general of israel to
the pacific northwest
console general of israel to the pacific
northwest mr shlomykovman is a 25 years
career diplomat
with vast experience in diplomacy tech
relations and public policy
prior to his posting in san francisco
consul general kaufman served as policy
advisor to the deputy foreign ministers
as israel's deputy consul general in new
york city chief of staff to ambassadors
in washington dc
deputy ambassador in thailand and deputy
consul general in shanghai
shlomi kaufman welcome to 20 minute
leaders all the way from california how
are you
great michael it's so great to be with
you thank you for thank you for finding
the time to chat with me and to
to tell my story the pleasure is all
mine shlomi you've had such an
incredible a history you know in
in foreign affairs and diplomacy uh what
you know some things that excite me most
besides the fact that you were a support
engineer you know back in the idf and or
but we're also in the ministry of
foreign affairs
chief of staff to of israel in the usa
in washington
a diplomatic advisor to the knesset and
now you're the consul general
uh out of israel to the pacific
northwest
and you know a lot of the people that i
have here on the show are coming from
the texting
entrepreneurs or investors and and this
is a unique opportunity for me and i
think for a lot of my friends
to get exposed to the type of work that
you do and the intersection of it in the
world
and and what your day-to-day life looks
like so xiaomi first
tell me what it means to be a consul
general and then i'll ask you to go back
in time a little bit and walk me through
some great milestones in your life
to that led you there and then we'll
think through some of the interesting
trends that we're seeing now including a
recent study that you've been doing
fantastic michael so thank you thank you
for this opportunity
um so what are we doing here
what what does it mean to be a consul
general constantine means to tell
israel's story
and to be there to represent the state
of israel to build bridges to the state
of israel
and and it's it's a work which is it's
it's 24 hours 24 7 work twins
and and it's a work that comes with huge
mission and huge belief in what we stand
for
and israel's values and and what israel
represents an israel's story and the
story of the people of israel
so so for me it's a mission which is
it's a never-ending story which is not
the job is never done because there's
always so much to do
and you know we kind of we cover five
states uh almost half of the five and a
half states uh northern california and
five other states
it's to be here in ambassador for israel
just to open doors
for people here to explain to tell the
story
and um it's one of the rema it's my
great discussion
amazing and so what does that tangibly
mean on the ground give me some examples
of how
telling the story actually takes place
across these five states
and you know you're you're a few
thousand miles from israel telling the
story of
of of this you know miracle startup
nation and you know there's a lot of
different ways to look at what's
happening but
how how is telling the story coming to
play with the day-to-day life
well what what what actually how does a
day look
it's meetings and really building
connections with elected officials
building connections in the academic
world with the jewish community
and uh and of course uh the tech
community and and businesses
look we cover from montana idaho
alaska oregon washington and northern
california
and for example in the past year we've
been doing like webinars with between
companies
in montana and israeli companies um
between
you know washington state and israeli
companies
so promoting building these bridges
communicating
introducing um you know
on other days we have meetings with i
have meetings with members of congress
or with people from the jewish community
and again it's telling these
story it's what's happening on the
ground whether it's politics but also
trying to shine light
of how do we connect to each other what
are the economic opportunities for
uh for the state and for the city and
for the company
with israel and there is so much to do i
mean there is so much on a daily basis
it's like again
it's a never-ending story so you know
going through
just a few short milestones in in your
journey because you've been in diplomacy
for a long time
what what is this role what does this
role mean to you having seen a lot and
experienced a lot was this
was this a a goal to be the consul
general of of the area that you're in or
did you imagine some different path
what is this for you well when you when
you embark
on on a you know on the diplomatic uh
work journey you usually
it's not just uh it's not a career it's
a lifestyle
you understand that you're going to
travel the world you move you
yourself in your family from a place to
place
in in different places is the the i
would say the character that
it the work varies but the mission stays
the same
and when you start your career is
basically usually
the i would say the the goal is to
become a head of mission whether
ambassador or culture general
and the concert general is is an
ambassador in a certain area
that in a big state usually like we
cover here again five and a half states
i have
other other colleagues who are who are
in other places and
when you you know when you're coming to
after years in a foreign ministry when
you're ready to become a head of mission
uh you can choose between whether you
want to be an ambassador to vietnam or
you want to be a consul general in san
francisco
or council jail in miami so and you you
present your
your candidacy you hope that the
committee will choose the first
your first priority but they even get
the third priority
and then you know for me san francisco
was the first priority that was lucky
enough to get it so
that's why i'm here amazing tell me a
little bit about about your current work
um and and some of the things that
you've learned
haven't i've been a consul general for
some time so
i'm you know i landed here after you
after seven years of working other
missions
uh in the united states um in in new
york in washington
and previously working with in uh you
know in asia
and i think like after after so many
years of working this
to this in this you know different areas
i came here with um with a deeper
understanding of first of all the
how how the area looks how was that
what's the important things
um and for israel this area is
crucial as much and in israel is very
important for this every as well
we're talking about um an area that is
very much connected
in tech right in academic work and then
jewish community in the philanthropic
work um
so although there are politically
sometimes challenges
uh that there are that arise here but at
the same time
the ties the deep ties between this area
the silicon valley and california
to israel are are incredible
and we are currently working on
together with um with bay area council
on study that will tell the story
that will tell california and silicon
valley story
with israel um it's a love story
it's a story that of entrepreneurship
the story of innovation it's a story
that
exploration it's a story of moving
forward
and making the world a better place it's
not for the good not just for the good
of
israel or silicon valley but
for the global good and when you have
you know when you have companies who
their first their major rnd centers are
in israel
and then their you know their their
devices or their software
is basically spreading around the world
that's that's the connection
right tell me how does that love story
impact
you know the demographics we're seeing
or the relationship we're saying
whether it be for israelis and in
california or the areas that you're
mentioning or whether it be
you know financially or maybe the
perspective of others on israel
what have you been observing so first of
all we're talking we're talking about
over around 40 to 50 000 israelis that
live in the bay area
and we're talking about in most of them
most of them are in town you're 50 000
we also have the patient
and you know you take seattle for
example
and in bellevue area you have around ten
thousand years
most of most of them are in tech so
the connection that and and the impact
that they're making
is incredible but they're making
incredible not only within the companies
but
also you know within their own
communities
and when you walk when you meet people
in in the silicon valley
and you say israel everybody says yes i
know
and then i know this guy now that guy
knows and
and this is you know that
is a representation here and that's so
important
and if you take you know if you even
dive into
berkeley for example berkeley for years
american university for years people
people used to say oh this is this is a
hotbed of of of bds and
and uh kind of anti-israel activity but
actually there's so much poor israel
going on there
there is israel studies uh institute and
jewish studies department and
it's incredible to see the strong
connection the
the the the this the
students are coming to study israel's
studies but also so many
so many scholars who are coming to
berkeley so you see this
this impact around us uh which is very
significant
and very and very um very supportive so
obviously your your
job as consul general it sounds like
it's a little bit different than
of other consul generals around the
united states or the world
because you have this unique
intersection of technology
and you're living in an area that the
the notion of israel
is perhaps a little bit less political
and it sounds like it's a little bit
more
financial and and business oriented
right
yeah yeah it's it is financial
it is business oriented it is tech
oriented um
and we see this we see this incredible
flow of companies
going on and more companies coming to
the bay area and more companies are
interested in israel
so we definitely would definitely feel
it um
and and you know even if you talk
politically also the political
connection is very strong you have a
very strong congressional delegation
here which is which is supportive of
israel
and and you know even speaker pelosi who
is representing san francisco and she's
been a friend of
incredible friend of israel for for
decades
so this area definitely has definitely
has
very very strong ties um you talk about
philanthropic
of philanthropies who are making the
connection
even stronger in different through
different circles so
very very um strong and and you know
for your point about other cultures i
think like different area in the in the
states
has different characteristics and they
support and the supportive
let's say uh elements are different than
than here uh you know whether it's los
angeles whether florida whether atlanta
so we're talking
with different character of um
you know different local character but
still lots of support so
me okay when i left israel to come to
university
i came as an israeli and i knew that i'm
israeli but but you know
given that we have 40 50 000 israelis in
california and obviously this
startup nation is a big part of the
israeli story
you know what what are what are some
perhaps non-trivial or hidden
responsibilities that
you know that we should be taking into
account as we are going abroad and we're
doing a lot of the
a lot of this work that at the end does
impact israel in some capacity
so it's 40 50 000 israelis not in
california at least
40 40 to 50 000 is raised in silicon
valley
uh but if you've got if you cut if you
count southern california and los
angeles so it's
the the numbers are much much higher uh
it's significantly higher
but look israelis are very special
people
and i'm saying it not because i'm
israeli but i think we're you know
living here in the states living in asia
uh we come with a lot of you know you
know
innovative spirit some sometimes cutting
cutting corners making things faster
not always it's it works everywhere but
i think
the beauty of israelis is by it's in
their nature and what they're bringing
to the table
it takes time to adopt but um
you know i think israel is not just
in israelis california not just the
brand name is not just
uh fauda and and uh but it's also a lot
of taking innovation
and uh and being a magnet look
you you go from the top guys in the tech
world and you in
and uh and um and your members of
congress and other people
and there is so much appreciation to
israel so much appreciation
to what israel has achieved uh to what
israel is striving you know i had
members of congress that they're talking
to me about
uh development of the negev and how
would you build it
and or or or water a lot of things to be
proud incredible and
uh and with you know every nation every
nation has
has its advantages and it has its uh has
its disadvantages and become
we can we have both right so but but but
our advantages are
i think and you know i think what what's
really interesting is we're looking at
the story of the jewish people
and we often are telling it as a story
of you know thousands of years old right
and
and yet we're looking at the story of
the startup nation that's really a story
of
30 40 years you know depending how far
back you look at
at the kibbutz and and the and the
entrepreneurs that build the irrigation
systems but
but you know really the startup nation
and and today the scale-up nation which
is really you know two
three years old we're looking at trends
moving very quickly the story of israel
is changing before our eyes
and is being told to the world in
different lenses which is also
obviously helping helping a lot what
what trend are you forecasting if we
look
five ten years down the line perhaps in
your area or
other areas what what are we seeing as
israel a part of the big world
well i think i think the reason more
there is a growing integration process
for israel in the world
but it starts in in our region and and
the
the abraham accords that we saw um
and kind of the the new bridges and your
this new relationship
uh with the gulf estate are definitely
um you know it's a trend and i'm sure it
will be it will this trend will continue
with the new government's trend that
that will
support and help easily to integrate
better
it will it will support the what is the
destabilizing forces in the middle east
and and it will support better economy
uh and we already see what the exchanges
between the gulf
states and israel and and that that
can this connection the business
connection the tourism between countries
will just establish and help to
integrate better better in the world now
with the abraham records and what came
with that uh
the roots to asia the cutting the the
the time cutting of the roots to asia
will also be a significant a significant
contribution we have a dark flash today
to latin america which we didn't have
for decades and
israel and israeli companies israeli
innovation
is a brand name and it's not just a
brand name
that you know just a kind of a marketing
brand
it starts from it goes bottom up
and it's the people who are bringing
that and that's the beauty of that so
i see and and the more you know looking
at the number of unicorns coming out of
israel
and the the companies that go public
the integration of israeli industry of
israeli society
of the technology is just i mean at the
moment is just
positive and on the right track
incredible and and slow me you know this
is an opportunity for me to personally
thank you for all the
for all the amazing work that you're
doing both you know as consul general
right now but but with a variety of
incredible positions that you've held
and and i can only imagine that
you know the experiences and the stories
that you've accumulated from all these
from all these experiences that we just
cannot share in you know
20 short minutes but but you know i'm
sure that your perspective
on on you know what what's happening
here is is an incredible one and thank
you for taking the time to share this
with me
and and i'm excited to share this with
the world but i do have
three short questions not about israel
but more about shlomi
and i want to take you back to your
childhood and ask you what what
fascinated you as a kid was it always
diplomacy
and international relations and foreign
policy what's fascinating
or what's always fascinated me was the
global world
and and coming from a family from a
zionist family that made the liar to
israel when i was nine
the world and and representing israel
was something that was very very much
keen and very very much interested
and you know i made my i made my uh
i succeeded to make my dream uh you know
true
and uh although i spent times in in
you know in tech it was uh being being
this position and being and having this
job is
amazing and what inspires you today so
as you go about your daily life or
you're thinking about
you know some of the questions some of
the difficult questions that you know we
were talking about
what what inspires you in your
day-to-day life i think what inspires
is what israel stands for and that they
know what it stands for
and it encourages me to go and tell the
story
and sometimes it's telling the story
against all odds
something is telling the story it's it's
it's finding a narrative
that is being thrown out there but
the the real
the reality the truth and the values of
israel
they inspired me and they give me the
feel to continue amazing
and last but not least three words that
you would use to describe yourself
passionate about my work passionate
about my family
and um and
have more power to keep going with that
thank you very very much
i look forward to meeting you in person
back in california
and until then stay safe and stay
healthy
you